what defined me
is not our words and my job it's what i
do believe it and they find me
i'm dominique and this is who i am
chef for unity is
people anywhere in the world that
believe in the same narrative that is we
have to unify
when they are in front of the their
camera and they break red i just want
them to say i stand for unity unifying
people is the number one thing that will
help the world to heal and the love to
show
[Music]
i want you to join this pledge by
posting a video or a picture of you
breaking bread
[Music]
lakshmi
garcia williamson michael montague and
tiffany join me on may 11th and let's
break bread together for peace unity and
ukraine
i pledge to break bread on may 11 to
raise funds and awareness for ukrainian
relief raising money for world central
kitchen please help us raise money for
those in need
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
three two one
live from l.a i'm chef ming tsai i'm
chef dominique and we are here for chefs
for you unity foreign
explain it why are we here
we are for love for peace for unity and
to raise money today for ukrainian
relief through war central kitchen our
mutual chef friend jose andres is the
hero of all chefs
he is the one that is going to help
change this world and he does it one
plate at a time his best line ever is
build longer tables not higher walls
right right that's right right and we
have all of these chefs here i work
they've been here all morning we've been
parting it up we've been cooking a bunch
we're gonna cook a little bit for you uh
and we're gonna talk to you about the
serious stuff that's going on in ukraine
right um and as chefs this is what we do
right i mean you and roberto solis right
you guys you had you brainstormed and
said
well you're sitting you see the war
happen and then you're like we get to
bring people together there you go so
roberto yeah roberto is the man anyway
that's right so so then we have
the other thing that's so important is
this is a fundraiser right we are here
to show the unity of chefs we're going
to break bread at the very end we're
going to have a very look great ceremony
that hopefully will bring and galvanize
the world together we have chefs all
around the world right now tuning in
she's fantastic all because of dominique
she she has an incredible reach of chefs
but we all have the same goal it's just
how can we give back how can we help the
people less fortunate i mean the
millions of ukrainians right now that
without jose they wouldn't be getting
food but to get food
we need to buy food so we need to raise
money we need to raise money so by the
way real quick to raise money right
there on the bottom of your screen you
can hit the donate button boom you can
also go to uh
wck.org chefs for unity right go to my
world
my world chef slash chefs for unity so
three places you could donate yeah and
then five five dollars ten twenty 20
100 000.
5 million or one dollar works okay dom
here's the first thing i made i made
bread right we're breaking bread so what
do you mean
scallion pancakes yeah i know what it
makes right okay
so cut that up for me these are scally
pancakes that's a stuffed bread with
scallions right
and then i have a little this what i
call the dim sum dipper oh good oh wow
look at this this is how three-star
michelin cuts up scallion pancakes
in the chinese restaurant we've already
paid our bill
we've already left the restaurant
all right so
now i think i love that because all over
the world we have different way of
making bread but the the only thing
that connects us is when we make break
we share bread we share bread and we
break bread i mean and look i think it's
absolutely key for everyone that's out
there
thank you for joining us um everyone's
always asked all of us chefs what can we
do and of course everyone would love to
jump in the plane go to border with
poland and cook right right but that's
not feasible so what you can do is just
open your pocketbooks and help us
because we are here to help jose andres
he literally has fed over 8 million
people in ukraine today which is
astonishing yes there's absolutely more
more needs to be done so
if i may i'd love to thank our sponsors
because without you we would be nowhere
we have san pellegrino we have won one
hope wines we have miyako creamy we
actually have yaku here she's a
superstar
and capital one so you guys thank all
four of you are really helping us out
how to donate
you know push the button donate you push
the button on the bottom of your screen
that's the easiest way to donate
i can't hear you
um
so
we're gonna bring on
uh your partner in crime yeah right
roberto roberto right roberto
uh so roberto
uh you know for how long
how many years i'm not telling you
you're not telling me oh my god oh so
they saw them roberto dominique
all right roberto you're around see
europe come here everyone give that to
our bedos
[Applause]
so roberto is one of the top 50 chefs in
the world
congratulations um you've been cooking
a long time right yeah that's a long
time and you're are you going to tell me
how long you've known dominique you're
going to keep it oh this is sacred
maybe okay
not an issue so
why are you here why why are why are we
all here we are here for unity for peace
uh to to help people in need uh i think
the only way to to do that and to
achieve that is to unite everybody to
unite everybody as much people as we can
for this cause
and to cook of course to make bread to
break bread and and i think food is our
way to
to do this yeah 100 percent that's i
mean it's not it doesn't matter what
country in the world you're it doesn't
matter what language you expect the
color you're using
it's the same philosophy peace is peace
right there's no give it just give it we
that's all we do give it keep giving and
giving to help others and i get to the
rumor has it i get to try your signature
right is that right yeah the voyage is
negra
come on really yes all right all right
you get to work all right get to work
it must be they must be good yeah
that's why it's 50 top in the world from
an onion i can't wait i can't wait
that's fantastic
all right so we have chefs
around the world too that
are not just here so we got a bunch of
chefs that actually want to say hi to us
right now so let's let's let them say hi
i think
ukraine right now
it's in the heart of many people around
the world
[Music]
for us was very important that we were
going to be here in this very difficult
hour
for all the people living in ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
be
[Music]
[Music]
with one plate of food at a time we may
not end this war
at the very least we're gonna make sure
that people don't suffer more than what
they have to
[Music]
now we are at our potluck table and look
at the bounty of this food wow
unbelievable amazing sherry yard did all
this bread and a lot of chefs here
cooked for this which is this is what we
do so well done everyone
really great i can't wait to dig in uh
we have two awesome
guests right here uh we'll start with
you first shirley and they are women too
[Laughter]
they're women too yes thank you i didn't
notice that
all right so shirley you've done
something so special i mean please look
at what you make these are these are
your dumplings right yes so and tell me
this story because it's it's so amazing
so we call this the freedom dumplings uh
we make this mushy cafe in my culvert
city restaurant
yeah look at this so they're in color of
ukrainian flags and inside is filled
with even though they're a chinese
dumpling shape they're filled with
ukrainian flavors chicken dill mushroom
binded with sour cream with horseradish
oh my god they're delicious thank you i
was inspired by the news i first got
when russia first attacked i see
grandmas and retired teachers got
together and folding dumplings in
ukraine to feed the front line and
dumplings is what i do my restaurant is
all about downplains
and
ukrainian is fighting for democracy
fighting for the whole world so i wanted
to do something
so we made we had made this dumplings
i got really emotional filled with
ukrainian flavors right by really
representing it's also the shape of a
rounding
classical ukrainian dumpling right
of a new moon representing new life a
new beginning oh that's beautiful that's
beautiful and you donated all the
products
yes so a hundred percent of this
dumpling privacy
i donated to war central kitchen also
directly to ukraine come back alive as
well fantastic and then i also started
with skull belly gold belly we love gold
belly
how come you're not on go belly
uh i'll help you out
so we had a nationwide campaign
of not only us but everybody on go
valley that making ukrainian flavors and
donate a hundred percent that's amazing
yay
good on you and good on goal belly
that's fair
and by the way
what we have to realize today is not
about who
is in charge of us or government but
it's the people that make a difference
so today we have to donate we have to
care we gotta care for our neighbor
because our neighbor is a brother and
sister so let's do this yep that's what
it is
thank you sir that's amazing
miyoko uh miyoko and i have i've chatted
before it's so great to see you great to
see you
you make amazing creamy butters and
cheeses but with a twist
absolutely so i really do believe that
this platform is a wonderful opportunity
to bring unity and equity around the
world not only for people but for all
living beings so what we do is we make
butter and cheese out of plant milk
instead of dairy milk but we use the
same traditional methods for
fermentation and aging etc to what we're
doing here and we partnered with chef
dominique krenn uh i am so honored uh to
launch this this butter package campaign
and we're not butter pack bread package
campaign and we're selling bread kits
uh donations actually with your butter
with our butter there's a a cube of our
butter in there right to raise we're
hoping a million dollars for ukraine
let's see let's see what i have here um
oh yeah look at this so this is the
bread you can get guys get those bread
kits get those okay give me some of that
all right you check that out tell me
what you think of it
i love when ming share by the way so
this is breaking bread right now between
two friends
i mean it's
i've told you this already this is the
best butter
it's probably oh jesus christ
okay well i don't know these guys said
best buddy
it is absolutely delicious but
uh both of you to just to dedicate
your time and your money and your
resources for world central kitchen for
the people in ukraine is is why we're
here right so
hats off to both and we want people to
how do you donate awesome question you
push the button at the bottom of your
screen that's an auto donate you can go
to wck.org
chefs for unity or you can go to my chef
world chefs for unity please donate two
dollars five dollars whatever you can
we so appreciate it because we we have
thousands of watching and a little bit
will go an incredibly long way
all right
so chef all around the world
by now
yes around the world we have chef
hello i'm chef tanya holland and i'm
here in downtown oakland at the cook and
her farmer with chef romney steel hello
and we are here to support chefs for
unity
and saying hello to our friend and
colleague dominique krenn yeah in
support to raise funds for uh world
central kitchen which we both
participated in and we're just sending
all our love love to support and we're
gonna break some bread break some bread
right here together okay let's do it
hey what's up chef quinn it's kelly
clarkson out here in los angeles i love
everything you and all the chefs for
unity are doing to support world central
kitchens ukraine fund no one should go
hungry ever especially in circumstances
that they can't control i hope everyone
watching will join in and support chefs
for unity and pick up the awesome chef
dominique
pandu me unity bread kid i really hope i
didn't mess that up i tried my best all
the proceeds go to world central kitchen
and then we can all break bread together
what
hey tom colicchio here chef and owner of
crafted hospitality
big shout out to dominique crenin chefs
of unity around the world uh in
solidarity we are raising money for
world central kitchen uh and their
efforts to feed the people of ukraine um
so together uh we can all break bread
and raise money for world central
kitchen
all right we have
new friends of yours but i first before
you my friend your friends of yours well
okay sorry new friends of mine old
friends are yours but i have to check
out what roberto is doing look at these
things he's frying he's frying
black
black opinions that's amazing that's
amazing black onions black onions matter
right well i i know you have a style of
cooking but there is other things in the
world that you can do that is
unbelievable i can't
oh my god oh do we get to eat some of
those
okay all right so
we have
you've heard this expression you've
heard this too rodolfo chefs are like
rock stars well we actually have a
rockstar
who um
had
one of the top 50 chefs in the world
right who new friend of mine
from chile so you know rodolfo
bienvenidos great to have you guys here
awesome so if i may start with you gavin
you you're not a chef but i know you
must appreciate great food because
you you know dominique well like i'm
giddy being here with all these chefs
awesome i love it so much it really is
uh it's uh
i love it i love i love to be around all
this creativity and all this passion
right all this love and the idea of
coming together for such a worthy cause
i'm just honored to be here
eat drink and try and convince people to
send money in
perfect right and you're gonna write
you're gonna write it
you're gonna write it always writes
you're gonna write a new song to
everyone that donates five bucks and
more is that right something like that
i'll sing it to them
and it'll come out in record form
and you can buy it right now
yeah vinyl final exactly that's the word
dude thanks for being on rodolfo you've
you've been a chef you've earned all
your michelin stars why are you here
well physically i'm supporting you know
tommy kim of course you know motivating
helping to motivate people to donate
so important so relevant
and and then in chile do you see
the same movement right chefs getting
together says how can we help because
every every country has their disasters
they're like rotates around the world
right absolutely food food community
it's it's growing and it's fantastic you
know we we all got together always
behind any kind of disaster
anything is
well you know
because it's like this
he's flying across the world
from cheerleading to los angeles every
day that's crazy i mean
insane
i see what what what i can't i can't
wait till you and i get to go to chile
and he's going to be playing music while
we're having
we'll feed you dinner we'll feed you too
don't worry so i i mean i i'm so happy
to have my friends here to support this
but there's another friend that is going
to be coming live
another michelin chat fantastic
okay so i don't have a mission stop but
i'm over it it's okay
he's jealous that's already so just all
right so let's let's see what let's see
what the chef has to say okay let's do
this okay
this is chef luca we are from georgia
and 20 percent of our country is
occupied by russia share crew and chefs
for unity are joining together around
the world raising funds for the world's
central kitchen ukraine fund together we
are making georgian traditional bread
tonight
in support of global unity join us may
11 to break bread
we stand together for the people of
ukraine slavo granules
hi kamil alves mcconaughey coming to you
from waco texas
with the women of today team on location
sending so much love for chef dominique
and all the chefs from unity around the
world coming together to raise funds
for world central kitchen
let's break bread together
beiges
hi i'm gail simmons and i'm coming to
you from brooklyn to send so much love
to my dear friend chef dominique grant
and all cooks for unity in solidarity
around the world to raise funds for
world central kitchen let's break bread
together or in my case snickerdoodles
hello alex hey
chef thanks so much for being with us
no thank you guys thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you i love you i love
you we love you
and i assume you're there cooking right
yeah we are doing that we're doing a
dinner there what are you doing there
alex
we are foraging and we are foraging and
also cooking tomorrow night
can you hear me he's going back to
nature wow wow yeah and canada what what
what do you what do you hope to find is
more or more are morels there i mean
yeah besides
mushrooms wild lake and delicious
delicious delicious food
wildlife well alex thank you so much to
be on today um we are so honored of
having you so
let's break bread together and raise
money for them i have a question for you
if i could
we're gonna break bread but i have a
question for you how
how do you use chef how do you use food
to bring people together that's a good
question how do you do how do you do
well
we do we try to do even more than this
uh me uh we try to use local flavors to
support indigenous people in brazil
through a tough foundation which uh ross
has helped quite a lot
making public so guys thank you and and
please everyone
try to help and try to donate some money
it doesn't matter how much it is
attitude is the the fundamental thing
for the near future so thank you dominic
thank you ming thank you ross
pesos too to godofo and everyone thank
you guys
oh awesome alex listen i want to show
you what
your fellow chef roberto is cooking
check this out so we're about to do it
so
we'll go ahead and tell them just in
case we're cooking some uh charcoal
you see
black onions
can we try now yes perfect
thank you so much for being on um
i can't wait to see you again and thank
you so much for being a part of this
beautiful
love uh piece
so good
so
and donate guys you guys got to donate
we need your money yes
my alex we love you alex we love you
thank you so much
everyone oh those are unbelievable
explain them so
just in case you're wondering and i know
you want to know we don't know how do
you donate it's super simple guys you go
to wck.org
accessory unity you can push the button
right there on your screen
you can also go to worldchef.com
unity and don't forget about the grunt
the exclusive pen to knee bread kit
yes how do you create a white pan to me
i mean you make lots of breads but why
pen to me what kind of meat is the bread
that i
wear eating every day my mom used to
make it it's kind of like i think a meal
no it's a charcoal
charcoal
[Laughter]
chef
[Laughter]
excuse me
okay hand to me your mom
and then we can you know
create a recipe people can buy the
product
and that has
this is my this is my last bread i made
for you this is also stuffed bread these
are ming's bings those are vegan gluten
free what do you think what is this so
it's a cheeseburger but it's vegan and
look we're breaking bread this is a
stuffed breast yeah i was like this
charcoal man it's like oh wow
hey who wants some minx bangs here you
go oh my god grab these guys vegan
gluten-free man stuffed bread
go to him
all right
we have more chefs that want to say hi
right now okay all right all right we're
gonna say hi to them
let's go
hey guys today i'm breaking bread with
my friend chef dominique krem and my
other fellow chefs for peace and unity
in ukraine
so i'm just gonna slice it
hopefully if you guys can join us in
raising money for ukraine relief
i'm chef justin
and i'm chef joe
we are coming to you live from miami and
we're at formula one standing in unity
and sending love to chef crane and all
the chefs all over the world
in support of world central kitchen so
let's break bread together
[Applause]
hey everyone i'm kyle kanat from single
thread in little saint in sonoma county
california and shout out to my good
friend dominique kran and all the chefs
who are supporting unity for ukraine
this amazing fundraiser that's happening
right now for world central kitchen
let's all break bread for peace so
dominique has friends from around the
world not like human no i do but i don't
have chests under the chef friends that
are this this
world yes new chefs
um we have there's our new friends
you've known manu for a long time no
manuba farah thank you so much for being
here uh and yvonne mutrada so much thank
you so much for being here again these
chefs traveled from around the world to
be here to support dominique to support
jose andres world central kitchen manu
if i may start with you i mean she's one
of the top latino chefs in the world top
50 hands down
why are you here
well i'm here because we have cows
we have uh a cows that we are here
together unity and well dominique
los andres
unity together for a cause i think
that's the reason everyone is here and
everyone is online and watching us right
i agree thank you sergey and yvonne
so i truly believe that uh giving is the
same as getting so i i truly believe
that
and encourage everybody around the world
to to give it's it's very important for
us in these days to
to contribute and give and support
uh our fellows
brothers and sisters around the world so
i think this is the reason why we're
here amazing so i'm gonna i'm just gonna
ask a selfless question if i came to
your restaurant in brazil what what
what's your signature dish that i would
be eating well uh we have a lot but the
the one is in on menu now it's just a
carrot uh so we're gonna go all the way
to brazil for a carrot yes
so we have like these uh a little you
know a message between the menu so we
everyone finished that the tasty menu
always we fish our meat and then we
finish with the carrot right you asked
us oh i'm coming i'm coming oh no you
know that's interesting i mean thomas
keller always says it's so much harder
to make a carrot taste good than a
ribeye that's yeah anyone can make a
ribeye
and aguamante if i show up to you i go
all the way to cabo san lucos um i think
we we are famous because of fish so i
will mention the sarandello fish that we
serve so we uh it's a sustainable uh
stride bass
farmed and um and close close to the
baja peninsula and uh we fermented with
a special type of miso made of uh
sunflower seeds and coconuts
and we might have them yeah that's so
funny that's in my new cookbook no it's
not
[Laughter]
not yet not yet
good that's awesome
it's just i mean dominique this is all
you it's amazing how you
just have the reach of love to bring all
of these chefs yeah but but people that
you know i know that i hang out
with and i'm an inspire
they care
you know
food matters and there is a purpose of
what they're doing so that's why they
are here that's absolutely so if you're
just tuning in we're here for ancestry
unity that's your spice from you know
about the ming's bank i don't know
because we cook real foods not like
crepes i mean seriously
we're here to raise money and the way to
do it there's three ways you have the
button push it on your screen that's the
easiest way anything guys five dollars
five dollars times like 10 000 people
that's real money right
you go to wck.org chefs for unity that's
one awesome website to easily and the
other one is myworldchef.com
slash chefs for unity all right and
don't forget 10 20 30 40. and her bread
kit don't forget her bread kit that's a
fantastic way to to to make bread and
please
if you have any questions or any
comments
shoot them to us we'll be happy to
answer them and i think we got about
five right now so we're gonna answer
those in a sec okay great right
so your questions are in your hand
oh
okay read the question
the five questions i don't have five
questions oh here we go
these are the audience questions i'm so
sorry i misread it
they want to know from you two chefs
what is your favorite dish
to eat
not to cook like when you go out with
your family or whatever at home
that i can touch eat by hands i love it
with my hands so you want to go to
ethiopia
right because it's all by hand right
literally they have no silverware no but
it's like something to you share you
know
and and
and in brazil what what would that be
what's that
tapioca yeah
[Laughter]
so
there's going to be a next generation of
chefs thank god right so
what advice do you have for their
success would you give to current cooks
now that maybe we all made mistakes yes
yes what advice would you get i think
it's the only thing it's like believe in
yourself
and creativity is not something that
you're born you can be created right so
i think it's uh
no one
believes you i see you can believe in
yourself so i think that's that's that's
a good idea it's a great one also
commitment commitment come in and
sometimes you have passions sometimes
you are talented but
you have to be committed to daily bee
that's right inspired to do um your best
to give to give uh food and the best of
you i don't i don't hire a cook if
they're not two years at every
restaurant right the ones that are six
months in eight months you're like what
why did you leave so right it's like
it's just don't there's nobody they
think that they they can't learning they
say
oh no i got it i understand chinese food
now boom they're gone they're gonna go
to france no you don't learn chinese
food in six months nor french should i
mean french food seven ones but no no no
and here's the one i love we're all
gonna answer it what's your guilty
pleasure what's your junk food what's
your thing you're like oh i can't wait
to gather home my french fries french
fries yeah i'm onion rings onion rings
is mine you um yeah i think it will be
chips chips
chocolate chocolate yeah tavia all right
we have to uh all right we're gonna go
we have more chefs
more chef i think we have more chefs
tuning in from around the world right
now check them out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys i'm with spike mendelssohn chef
mike wilson right here and a bunch of
amazing people we're in burgundy
and we're breaking bread today we've got
some qualm bread here
we
that's right and we've been cycling all
over the place but we're here and with a
bunch of amazing people from all over
all of this is just our table yes we've
got
psalms and chefs and people we've been
cycling but we're actually here i mean
we've been raising money for all kinds
of stuff but we're here to
to break bread
with dominique and world centre kitchen
and we're supporting ukraine yes
what's up everybody chef marcus samson
here harlem at the red rooster big shout
out to chef dominique cran and all the
chefs that came together
and worked together to raise money for
world-centric kitchen and unity for
ukraine what world center kitchen is
doing right now is so important for the
people of ukraine but also feeding
people around the world and one of the
simplest way we can do that is to come
together and break bread
all right
we have chef russell jackson here hi
rachel meanwhile
jackson
and we have chef sherry yard coming in
too but she's working harder than all
these other chefs so russell first
question where are you from uh
originally i'm born and raised in l.a
but i actually live in harlem new york
you do that's true i was just there with
marcus and everyone with jose
celebrating celebrating his new movie
jose has a great new movie up feeding
your people produced by ron howard it is
unbelievable
movie right
and we have
dominique crenk cooking for us russell
what do you think about that well it's
about time it's about time
i've been waiting all day
you know don't burn yourself
i need to know what are you cooking
there that looks amazing i'm not trying
thing i'm cooking things you know very
slowly are you saying like you didn't
take something out of the freezer and
put it in an air fryer like i did is
that what would you do this is a beauty
because that's what i did this is a
beautiful street bud uh street baths
that we actually bass strip bass is that
club down the road that's a whole
different club striped bass stream badge
but it's funny enough we were all there
last night
here we go we go we can have like egypt
a little bit of uh
shirodashi olive oil a little bit of
lemon okay
is basically japanese flavoring liquid
it's like it's like soy sauce on
steroids right
and how long did that take to cook dump
about 10 minutes no
that's awesome chef how would you cook
that for so good about 30 minutes uh 45
45 30 45. okay
all right so come here dog now we've
seen the final product will you show us
how you
how do you make it what do you do this
is not the final product no now that
we've seen the final product merci
all right so so this look at this
beautiful fish so uh
a beautiful uh
fish monger that gave us to that so we
kind of age it for like five days uh in
your fridge do you hang it or you just
no i was i was uh helped by this amazing
there's an amazing uh fishmonger here in
los angeles uh levi that's just we call
it the dry
diet dry you try that yeah you got it
the dry aging yeah yeah man
edge it for five days to get the flavor
beautiful and then we just grill it you
know and what did you suffer with let me
see this
salt pepper
and then let's lemon and that's it then
we uh we brush it with olive oil and
shiodashi
and then that's it that's it so
shirodashi is like your go-to magic
sauce this is my butter
that's shirodashi guys
it really is it's it's all that it's
delicious it's amazing
it's like yeah it's like sauce on
steroids and then we're gonna finish
with like a little bit of lemonade what
is this so so this is what we uh make at
actually crane you know
um we don't waste anything right so
whatever leftover or things that we
don't use you know to serve to the
customer we ferment and this is a
baloney exo sauce
exo sauce yes nice i love that the
french chef is making an exo sauce
so traditionally exodus what it is exo
sauce
oh traditional exo sauce
is actually
an incredibly expensive sauce to make
using dried scallops so if you go to
hong kong and some parts of china in the
south guangzhou you have these huge
glass jars of all these scallops
some of them are up to like 200 a pound
crazy expensive but that with garlic and
ginger and spice is the base of exo
sauce i it's it's classic on scallops
right steamed scallops and exo sauce but
i've used it on everything and right i'm
i'm humbled you're using an exo sauce
well it it's so it's it's it's to also
use the thing that come from the farm or
the things that they are in the kitchen
so we don't rest so fermentation don't
worry about it i'm not going to give you
the recipe right now it's a pita pita
miso
what was the recipe
exactly what do you think
oh
there's shallot yeah there's garlic yeah
there's obviously some fermented dried
fish
of some sort yeah probably
it's abalone interesting
uh there's some shirodashi and or soy
one or two yep
um
oil to cook it all yeah
um but there's no cilantro no none of
those herbs it doesn't need it nope and
there's no fermented black beans either
no peanut i think no pepitas or
sunflowers yeah yeah that's right that's
it that's right it's wild that's going
in my new book too along with the black
onions and the other ones the thing is
is is what it means is
cooking has no border
so peace has no border right so unity
has no border is you all unify everyone
that's how we do it donate huh so for
those are for those that may not have
donated yet or for those that want to
donate a second time we love you wck.org
chefs for unity or my world kitchen
sorry
myworldchef.com
chefs for unity great or just push the
button on your screen that's why we're
here guys we've got chefs literally from
around the world um eating drinking can
we eat your fish yeah yeah let's see if
your chef took your cooked fish i want
to eat it
i'm sure you
sherry yard are you here
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen this is sherry yard
sherry i've known sherry for over two
decades sure
uh not actually longer actually it's
probably three it's probably three two
all of this bread which is amazing this
is fun
this is the panda this this we're gonna
we're gonna do a ceremony with us
because he's such a beautiful brand
uh i've again i've shares with wolfgang
puck for 20 years that's not the only
thing she's done but that kind of
solidified her career and now she's
semi-retired making food for 30 chefs
we're having fun eating
she's starting having fun in her life
got it and you're eating johnny and
vinnie's meatballs and my buns yeah your
beans oh baby they're balls awesome
you've always
you've always done every event that
we've done together right we just we're
just saying
right you've done so fortunately we've
been so we're so lucky so that so
tell tell the people why what inspires
you to do that make me cry oh no i'm not
going to make you
in the restaurant business and
hospitality business we're so blessed
and fortunate we work our butt off but
we appreciate people that that fight and
and are standing up for good and that's
what's happening here you know it's it's
kind of um
you know just it touches my heart so
much
that we can come together and help
others
uh and my goodness jose
what he does we all stand behind him
he's such a leader
he is just a paramount in this industry
and anything we can do to help everyone
out there we're here for you oh sure
you're the best oh my god it's not for
bread just one loaf of bread
exactly buy one love for bed make one
little donation and russell can i just
ask you what
you obviously you you've cooked for
thousands and thousands of people right
i mean this is a few people here so
what why are you here well
i'm here because she said i needed to be
first off and
you know
this is this is my friend and
when my friend's in need
she makes a request
if i'm in need i make a request and
we've never failed each other throughout
all the years that we've been together
and
we have a friend in jose and jose asked
her to do this and by extension she
asked all of us so
how could how can you say no
first off we don't and then but
since the beginning of the pandemic
through all of this now a war
all the fires the floods all the things
that we've all been through
he's always been there and he's always
stepped up for all of us to make sure
that we were capable of feeding other
people because our job is to feed people
to take care of their souls and their
hearts and their stomachs yeah and
that's you said it that you that's
perfect that's exactly why we're here
there's an old chinese expression called
harin halbal
which is basically good things happen to
good people that's right
because it's karma it really is and and
but the
none of us are doing this to get
anything back no right what people
i hope you understand to me and i think
to all of us yes true success is not
what we get it's what we get give yes
that's true success if you get to give
like this and raise money for world
central christian and for all the people
in ukraine oh my god we're huge
successes when you give it once it feels
like you get back ten times a hundred
percent and and then also you know and
and i agree with you because that's what
i feel about success but we
have been giving a platform
and the platform for us
is to show up for the people that don't
have a voice doesn't matter what it is
it's that is it's not political it's
nothing it's humanity at its core and
that's what a true human is is someone
that give out there without thinking of
giving something back but knowing that
what he does with the purpose of giving
will change somebody life so that's why
we are that that's amazing awesome well
again we have more chefs from around the
world that want to come and do a shout
out let's see who these guys are
russell thank you thank you thank you
so i'm chef don from the new restaurant
with my team from bangkok thailand and
today we're sending the love to chef
clean and all the chef for unity all
around the world to restaurant for
health the world central kitchen for
ukraine let's break the bread
[Applause]
hey everybody andrew zimmern here and
i'm coming to you live from my home
kitchen i'd like to salute my friend
chef dominique
and all the other chefs around the world
who are participating in this incredible
activation together
chefs for unity all in the hopes of
raising dollars and awareness for wc
kitchen that is world central kitchen we
absolutely love that cause and you chef
jose andre so let's all break bread
together or
bite apples whatever we happen to have
on hand
all right guys we got all the chefs we
got daniel blue coming in coming in hot
but
i wanted to say one thing
we are getting donations right now we
just saw a thousand dollar donation come
in so thank you
we just got we have a corporate donor we
just have strategic group just we'll
match the next 2500 donated they will
double it so put in five bucks you just
donated 10. so thank you strategy you
could redo that smash that donate button
guys we really need it all right so
danielle's coming in hot i i would
presume he's in new york
daniel boulud sorry as opposed to
danielle craig
because he's a hell of a good shaken not
stern
uh daniel blunt is a two-star militia
chef of course he's one of the world's
best chef uh he does so much the other
thing we haven't quite touched on but
this is how every one of these chefs do
is we mentor and that's it and one of
one of his closest organizations with
with thomas keller and jerome beaucous
his mentor for team usa right that's
right um and everyone here we all mentor
right we we all started as a plunger a
dishwasher or somewhere and we had
danielle
[Applause]
thank you thank you and all the chef
around the world
what we are doing for world control
kitchen what we are doing for rose what
we are doing for chef for unity
has to continue and get stronger and
stronger it's so important and today is
such a big day because we want everyone
watching to give something to be able to
be there to support by the way i was in
the middle of my miserables
for my oyster vanderbilt
which is an oyster that has been
stuffed with a oyster shelter
as a nuts leaf
pork oysters and a crust of seaweeds and
herbs on top
and but here today
we are here to we are here to break
bread
and
of course this is a french baguette
but it don't matter where you are in the
world
everybody knows how to bake bread
everybody knows how to share bread
and everybody knows how to
give bread as well because bread is the
one the most wonderful gifts you can
get
and so
do i break bread
to peace
to unity to chef for unity
to you dominique
ming
for being self-leader
and aspiration
[Applause]
awesome so i want
go ahead
well while
so so danielle i just the one question
we have of course is are our oysters
vanderbilt twice as expensive as oysters
rockefeller
is that how you did it
of course
of course i i admired rockefeller
but i am in a building for one
vanderbilt and i needed we needed to
honor vanderbilt as well
of course awesome danielle
we love you thank you thank you
we love you and we're gonna do a minute
of silence very soon everywhere around
the world we are getting ready for that
we are waiting for your moment to tell
us
it's it's coming it's coming soon merci
beauzoo to you all thank you so much all
right we love you guys
all right now i'm so psyched guys we
have the man himself jose andres tuning
in live he's gonna come in
and and say a few words so we're just
trying he's traveling somewhere and
bluntly he didn't have great cell phone
coverage because he's traveling
somewhere and he's going to be coming in
live
and he froze all right so wait everyone
freeze
in honor of jose
and we all freeze
is he still frozen
is is jose still frozen
how the hell are we going to drink wine
okay
yeah that's going to be a mess all right
so let me just cut
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell cut let's just
let me just tell you who is jose andre
says um although you know what i agree
we have a mission video
on world central kitchen and this by far
will drive home exactly what world
central kitchen does why all of the
chefs are here and why jose is jose
oh wait he's here live
yeah he's not frozen never mind hold on
[Applause]
hola
how are you buddy
i can't hear
you tell everybody
thank you for asking
uh he was on mute oh you're a mute okay
yeah i know
sped up muted
spanish i believe
yes how are you my friend
so guys where are they
i am in cadiz in the south of spain
and i've been filming a tv show for
discovery
and from here i will be on my way back
to uh ukraine
so
what i can say uh dominic uh as always
uh you you are you are a saint you are
i love you
uh obviously with the support of me and
so many chefs i always love
the leadership that you've been taking
dominic in so many ways
not only being
one of the best chefs in the world
but also been such an amazing friend
such an amazing mother
son i'm such an amazing chef and then
leading the way helping race fans
um at the end of the day guys what we
are doing in ukraine we are all doing
that
everybody is doing that
some of us we can be there other people
are in poland or the people are in
romania or the people are in moldova or
the people are in spain or germany or
poland or hungary
everybody is doing their part
and what i want to say is this
technology we are already over 20
million people just you know what jose
was saying is just
are you able to hear me
are you able to hear me
call of duty anyway so we're going to
play a mission
guys please please pay attention to this
all right let's roll this guys roll the
mission video
freeze
okay are we on camera right now we're
still on camera these two rabbis walked
into a chinese restaurant
well they did
okay jose is coming back
welcome back i don't know what part what
part of my speech you heard but what i
want to say thank you thank you dominic
thank you ming thank you to everyone
that has joined you on on this amazing
celebration
um
building longer tables no higher walls
breaking bread
uh i think it's something the cooks the
chefs of the world
yeah
so my crap my pregunto to you is why is
right now so important why is now the
time to give
well listen to me we i wasn't dragging
in ukraine
we arrived already to over 20 million
meals
20 million 20 million meals guys that's
amazing that's wait 20 million we have
more than we have more than
450 restaurants
that we are supporting
all across ukraine
making
hundreds of thousands of meals every day
right now we are doing our 350 000 meals
a day
we are in more than 750 shelters we are
in eight countries where in 110
ukrainian cities
uh i can tell you right now that in some
corner across ukraine
is a chef with all central kitchen
feeding somebody in need why this is
important right now
because there's many people around the
world that need us and i believe more
chefs like us we're gonna be there i
think it's about time that chefs we take
over
in trying to find creative ways
to end hunger in america to end hunger
in the world and in emergencies being
next to the people that need a plate of
food in a dark hour the chefs of the
world together i do believe in the next
25 50 years we can be
the leading force
to solve many of the problems we face
when food sometimes is not available
what you are doing today dominic is
important because you are helping to
bring the entire chef food restaurant
community together
i'm telling you again together we will
end hunger i believe we can do it you
are showing me the way you are showing
us the way thank you for this initiative
guys
thank you jose's last night together we
will end world of hunger that's so right
jose
mia gracias thank you we'll see you soon
thank you thank you
love you thank you buddy we'll see you
soon
all right guys
perfect timing to see world central
kitchen's mission video
[Music]
and the tracks we're going to be able to
i think yes
this is ukrainian
oh i don't know i think russian it's
then
[Music]
and we're coming back tomorrow
we're not going to be solving the very
big problems that humanity is facing
without certain risk involved if we want
to end hunger we are going to have to
take certain risk to make it happen
the only way i can do it is with being
with the boots on the ground next to the
people that you are trying to help
24 7 bus stations 24 7 hot food milk
baby food everywhere sir everywhere
300 000 meals a day for the last few
weeks three hundred thousand meals
thousand points of distribution carson
nikolai oh this
[Music]
[Music]
tomorrow we are coming back with more
[Music]
chef
friends
beautiful friends we are here to uh
come together for uh unity peace and
love so what i'm gonna ask you guys to
do
and all over the world to take a moment
of silence
to think about
really what freedom is and to understand
that we need to be a part of true
freedom
tell me
five four
three two
okay this is amazing that was awesome
what we're gonna do right now we're
gonna let's break bread break bread we
have show yards epi everyone grab a bowl
and we get one bowl
oh you do i have my bowl
breaking bread the most important things
that a human to human can do sharing
loving breaking bread all right
to world peace to all place
please don't all right guys real quickly
this video is available on demand so
please share it and continue to donate
to sport world central kitchen and our
buddy jose andres
huge thank you from chesapeake humanity
right you guys
thank you for being here there's nothing
more than just showing up
thank you
what did i say show us what you might
humanity okay and humanity chester unity
sorry
every chef here
jose andres daniel balloud alex
thank you for all tuning in all the
chefs around the world thanks for tuning
in the sponsors sam pellegrin one hope
wines miyoko's creamery and capital one
thank you thank you thank you
and thank you
world chef for an incredible production
of this and to you dominic thank you for
gathering all of us together and for all
you out there thank you for watching
go donate and please
be kind
you'll feel better and break some bread
with not only your friends and family
but with complete strangers that's what
we have to do dom last word
the only world that i have is love
and i hope that you watch today
something that is not just about the
today but it's about the tomorrow and
probably forever so please
be a part of this movement
peace and love donate please thank you
okay bye bye guys take care
[Applause]
that was great
that was fantastic that was fantastic
you